dragon is a man shrouded in mystery it's
time to change that
[Music]
let's be real for a second what is it
with mysterious characters in one piece
that barely have any screen time shanks
the goro say blackbeard there's just
nothing more fascinating for me than
talking about these people who are
incredibly influential and powerful in
the world at large but that we know
close to nothing about
you
and monkey dragon is definitely right in
there with more gossip and room around
him than in a middle school yard i want
to know what this man is all about hi my
name is manu i generally assume that if
you have a face tattoo you've lost
control over your life but today i'm
willing to look past that and analyze
dragon's role in the story and of course
this wouldn't be fun if we didn't
speculate a little bit so i have two
really solid theories about his past and
one that is just so bad
crazy that it would be a crime not to
share with you i'm trying so hard to
ignore this face tattoo right now it's
so distracting
how drunk were you when you got this is
this like a post malone thing so why did
you decide to get the tattoo i know i
decided to take down the draconic
all-powerful ruling force that dominates
the entire planet and then i thought if
i really want people to take me
seriously i should probably change my
look to something that inspires more
respect okay anyways let's figure out
dragon's role in the story so far this
man holds two pretty impressive titles
he is both the father of our protagonist
as well as the most wanted man alive
that is some roger level infamy we're
talking about here let that sink in for
a second luffy's father is a bigger
threat to the world government than
kaido big mom blackbeard i mean yeah we
talk about that all the time but seeing
luffy actually fighting the two yonko
right now that really hits home
different i think now while i think it's
fair to assume that dragon is actually
really powerful i think we all agree
that a big chunk of this title is for
political reasons which in my eyes makes
him even more interesting what does
dragon have that even the yonkos don't i
want to get into that in just a second
but first let's talk about the monkey
family as a whole
now there are a lot of weird and
influential families in one piece yes
yes there are but luffy's family in
particular stands out among even that
crazy sets luffy himself is the rising
star of the pirate worlds the next
pirate king and most likely the man
prophesized to change the world by the
way did you know that in the italian dub
of one piece luffy is called
rubber bro they just completely removed
monkey d and changed luffy to rubber so
for half the anime he simply straw had
rubber until they then apparently
realized they [ __ ] up when the name
became more important later on his
grandfather garp is the great hero of
the marines who went head to head with
the strongest pirates in the world while
his father dragon is the founder and
leader of the revolutionary army tasked
with taking down all of the world nobles
the pattern of three that oda really
really really loves is very prominent
here each of the three represents the
top level of each of the 3 major
factions in the worlds marines pirates
and revolutionaries
all three of them share a strong sense
of justice freedom and camaraderie and
are brave and tough to a ridiculous
level
all three of them care about the people
around them and put their quote-unquote
work family over their real family i'm
not really sure if work really fits here
that's good to hear so what do you do
for a living actually oh i'm a pirate oh
okay that's pretty cool how's the pay oh
well it depends how much money you got
on you right now and interestingly
enough all three have a mark on the left
side of their face luffy and garb have a
scar while dragon
dammit just when i sort of forgot about
the tattoo
now the monkey family has most likely
been inspired by the legend of the three
wise monkeys you know them because they
turned them into [ __ ] emojis
one covers his eyes and sees no evil one
covers his ears and hears no evil and
one covers his mouth to speak no evil in
essence this story is about cultivating
a mindset that will create a world of
harmony peace and goodwill do you see
the connection now what defines all
three luffy garp and dragon is that they
are genuinely good people who fight for
a world in which everyone can live a
happy life regardless of who they are
garp of course represents the best side
of the marines luffy has all sorts of
racist and quirky characters in his crew
but so does dragon in fact looking at
the people associated with the leader of
the revolutionary army really hammers
home the fact that he is luffy's parents
[Music]
a group that is prosecuted in this more
or less conservative worlds sabo a
former noble who has seen the cruelty of
the royals you have huck a fishman
representing the revolutionary version
of jimbei of the fishman fighting for a
better and equal life among the other
races with koala you have a former slave
that was an important link between
fishermen and humans
[Music]
[Music]
lindbergh like chopper would probably be
considered a freak of nature bello betty
is as strong and independent a woman as
you'll ever see and you also have kuma
or as he's called in german bartolomeo's
beer i love that who connects the
revolutionaries to vagapunk and the
government itself
my point here is dragon has luffy's crew
but on a global scale he shares his sun
ideals only that he chose a much more
active path to follow them so no wonder
that he would approve of the route that
luffy has chosen to become pirate king
now just a side note i'm not a parent
myself but i dare say that's some
questionable parenting right there if
i've ever seen one i think it's never a
good sign that when someone mentions
your father your first reaction is
basically
i have a father
well i can somewhat relate to that
before recording this video i checked
the notes and i have a sponsor i think
my father is proud of me now
well this video is sponsored by
skillshare the caring parent of sponsors
who have supported this channel for a
while now big thank you to them
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes for all skill levels in tons of
creative and practical disciplines i'm
taking this class on productivity by the
amazing thomas frank right now because
my schedule at the moment can best be
described as hell the first 1000 of you
foxes to click the link in the
description below will get a one month
free trial of skillshare so you can
start exploring your creativity today
i'm getting really good at this maybe i
should make a skillshare course now even
more interesting than his crew i think
dragon has popped up in the most
peculiar places he was at rogers
execution who inspired pretty much
everyone there in some way or form and
he came back for luffy's execution as
well to see him off for the beginning of
his adventure he was at shimotsuki
village at zoro's dojo to restock
supplies and he took in robin for the
time skip who got sent to him by kuma
who is part of the revolutionaries
himself
so i think it's not so much speculation
as it's a fact that dragon has an active
interest in the true history i really
don't buy the dragon sought out robin
simply because the enemy of my enemy is
my friend i think we all agreed that
they had things of importance to discuss
and robin probably knows quite a bit
about dragon's plan as luffy most likely
supposed to play some role in it but on
top of that dragon wouldn't be the most
dangerous man in the world if he didn't
have some specific knowledge and the
power to back it up what makes him such
a big threat to the government is that
he subscribed to my channel for next
generation anime content that the goro
say fear above all else now that's
already a pretty big advantage but there
must be a bit more to it i think and
just so you know from here on out we're
entering speculation territory two
popular ideas are the dragon used to be
a marine or cipher pole agent and that
he ate a devil fruit that allows him to
control the weather of wind as it always
seems to change in his favor when we see
him
just like zorro however i want to leave
the known path here and introduce some
more unknown ideas as well the first of
these is that dragon might not have a
super broken devil fruit but that the
revolutionary army is actually in the
possession of uranus one of the ancient
weapons not your butt we do know from
shiki that roger found an ancient weapon
and that he managed to escape shiki
without even fighting by a sudden change
of the weather
we do know that the first ancient weapon
is a ship on the sea the second is
shirahoshi under the sea so it would
just make sense that the third weapon is
above the sea and it's not too far a
stretch to speculate i think that it's
able to control the weather or wind now
if dragon was wielding one of the three
weapons that the government fears so
much that would explain why he is the
most wanted man in the world especially
since he is aiming that weapon straight
at the world nobles another thing okay
hold on you know what i can't look past
that let's talk about that tattoo for a
moment why does dragon have it he didn't
have it at roger's execution so why does
a man so driven by purpose that he left
his child to be raised by his
grandfather who in turn left it to be
raised by some bandits why does such a
man get such a tattoo it must have some
deeper meaning the first possibility i
think is a connection to shandora where
tattoos are quite popular and that
follow the same abstract style now i
really like this connection because
robin tells us that the shendorans used
to fight against the world government
and were allied with the ancient kingdom
or if you watched the greatest one-piece
theory of all time on my channel it
might actually have been part of the
ancient kingdom
there is a connection to the ancient
weapons and the sun got nika even raj
was there so i think it's not super out
there that dragon knows something about
the shandorian history and that symbol
in particular that he found so important
and meaningful he decided to tattoo it
on his face
the other option is actually even more
interesting though this theory comes
from a youtube friend of mine called
fiji shout out to fiji who found that
dragon's tattoo resembles the one on the
kimono of the one and only legendary
samurai ryuma
in this version of the symbol there is a
kanji in the middle of the square which
means what exactly dragon which is a
peculiar coincidence don't you think but
i think if this were the only connection
to wano that would be a bit of a weak
link only thing is that we saw dragon
arriving at shimotsuki village named
after the daimyo family ryuma was part
off
as i woulda hinted that in one of his
interviews dragon has actually some sort
of relationship with the dojo master
koshiro who is a shimotsuki himself
which is confirmed in sbs-96 and so what
fiji suggests based on this is that
dragon might potentially have travel to
wano that similar to shandora is another
place connected to the ancient kingdom
and the poneglyphs and thus might have
been of interest to him to search for
knowledge or even potential allies now
this probably would have happened
roughly 18 years ago when shimotsuki
ushimaru who based on his appearance we
now speculate heavily to be zara's
father was killed by kaido
kaido not
so the reason dragon knows about
shimotsuke village might be because he
traveled there before 18 years ago after
he went to wano befriended ushimaru who
then with the other daimyo planned their
rebellion and got captured and so he
then took zorro from wano to his
relatives in the east blue ushimaru
could have told dragon about his
ancestor yuma and their ties to the void
century so there might actually be some
deeper meaning behind the symbol that
dragon then decided to tattoo on his
face after leaving wano now i do think
that this idea rests on a lot of
assumptions but i think it's solid
enough to make sense and i think it
would really really nicely fit in the
gaps for zorro that i discussed in his
video plus it would really add to the
close bond between him and luffy however
while this theory is very creative and
out there it still makes a lot of sense
and if you know me the crazier theory
the better i can sleep at night so i
want to end this video on something
truly crazy now a really interesting
idea is that dragon is actually not garp
sun but rocks however liam over at the
grand land review has already made a
video about that the sneaky bastard so
of course i have to top that one by
proposing that dragon is not garb's son
but garb's daughter
i told you this was gonna get wild okay
so if you're a real one-piece fan you'll
have come across the idea that crocodile
actually used to be a woman that is
luffy's mother that then was transferred
into a man by ivankov his quote-unquote
dark secrets
[Music]
i don't know why but people love that
now this theory is similar but takes it
even a step further let's go down this
hormonal rabbit hole here for a second
the base idea is that all the devil
fruit users in the revolutionary army
have a power that helps them operate in
secrecy avoid detection and rely alleys
to their side not counting sabo in this
for obvious reasons now morley can
create hidden underground spaces like
under marijuana or impul down that can
serve as bases and move troops bellow
betty can enhance people's powers and
strengthen their will to fight karasu is
basically an entire private
communication and evacuation system and
then there is ivankov who also can boost
up people's bodies but much more
importantly change entire identities
many members of the revolutionaries are
criminals pirates or slaves who are
wanted by the government and so
ivankov's abilities can give them a
fresh start a clean sheet by changing
their bodies which is where dragon comes
into play
dragon is a complete mystery to pretty
much everyone he's a man with no past
except his connection to garp and luffy
but this is also strange no one was
aware that dragon was garb's child the
hero of the marines i mean garp is as
public a figure in one piece as it gets
and yet no one knows he had a kid it
would make sense for garb not to boast
about it after he became a revolutionary
but complete ignorance is pretty
astonishing i think
[Music]
so what this theory suggests is that
garp had a daughter that quote unquote
died but actually turned into the dragon
we know today in fact garp never refers
to dragon as his son now from there on
out the theory then goes on to speculate
that luffy's real father is actually
roger and that dragon was sent into the
future by toki which is where i
definitely jumped the ship but in
general i found the idea that dragon is
actually luffy's mother very very
entertaining to say the least more so
than the crocodile one to get the full
picture on the monkey family however i
strongly recommend you watch this video
on garp here next cause there is a lot
to talk about with him as well